Welcome everybody.
Today
we are going to talk about world models.
Very exciting topic. But before that I
wanted to give a quick recap
from the midterm feedback that we
received. Very excited for all of you um
that it seems that
things that were well received were like
the main lectures and especially the the
guest lectures.
And
I also put like some
um
>> [clears throat]
>> some comments from the feedback
that were kind of like repeated in in
different words mostly
through through the different feedback
forms.
But yeah, I think in general it seemed
that
yeah, people
criticized a little bit that the paper
presentations on Monday were a bit
rushed and sometimes difficult to follow
and so forth. And that people also would
appreciate having a break. So it's not
like you know, two hours straight off of
lecture.
So
we will
try to improve this.
Oh yeah, and some people also said that
more credits would be
deserved for the workload.
I originally requested more credits from
ETH but yeah, that's the university
didn't feel like more credits were
deserved. So
that's not my choice.
But
yeah, we will try to improve things
because we agree with a lot of the
feedback that you gave gave. And so we
will move one additional paper
presentation from the Monday slot to
Thursdays in order to create a bit more
time.
Because also a lot of people said that
they also wanted to
have a little bit more
uh time devoted to the main lectures.
>> [clears throat]
>> And so, we will try to achieve this
starting today.
Uh so,
um
I will either talk a bit longer or the
same as before, I'm not sure. Let's see
how it goes.
Um and uh we'll try to make a break in
between um like uh after the main
lecture
uh before starting the uh first paper.
And um then with the guest lecture from
today.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> Before we start, I'll also briefly touch
upon the project.
Uh
cuz that's [clears throat] um kind of
now the very exciting things that we
will start with
uh starting this um
this this next weeks, right? The group
projects.
Uh we already uh all of you um
um
participated [clears throat]
in this amazing uh robot assembly
exercise 2 weeks ago. And now we want to
like um take all the things we've been
learning so far in the course uh and
train some policies for for these
robots, right?
Um
we will have uh five projects and
competitions.
Um I will briefly uh touch upon them.
Um but they're uh also like the TAs will
provide also more
uh details on the project. Um the key
dates
uh or the key information that um is
important for you to know is
>> [clears throat]
>> uh we will have a demo day on the main
uh building on the 21st of May.
Uh and for each of these five projects,
um
like there will be some
like evaluation criteria on how points
are uh will be assigned for each team.
Um and then for each of the five main
projects, uh
the best team will um have the chance to
do the demo of their project a week
later on the um
29th of May.
Uh
to also uh
uh selected uh Robot Learning VIPs that
will be visiting ETH on that day. Um cuz
that's like a a workshop that also Mark
and others are organizing in Switzerland
uh on that week. And uh
they will be inviting a lot of these
people like Jan LeCun, Sharan, Jitendra,
and so forth uh to ETH.
Uh I can't promise that all of them, you
know, will come or be there to see like
your demo, um but the chances are very
high. Um we're trying to uh trying to
make that work. Um so that also would be
a very nice reward.
Um and finally uh I'm
um
very excited to announce that
uh we got some support from uh Nvidia in
terms of compute
uh to support um all of your uh group
projects.
Um and so we have around um
12,500
hours of H100 compute. Um and I think
it's a um
around 277
uh H100 uh compute hours uh per team. Um
and um yeah, we will uh also give more
explanation uh shortly on how you can
access um the compute um uh with all the
details and so forth.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right. Um
so we will have we will we are trying to
make kind of like one project per main
paradigm that we are covering in in the
lecture,
right? Um and so the first project will
be
centered around
training VLA models.
And
So, here, well, this is a little of a
little bit verbose, but essentially,
like the evaluation criteria, as you can
see,
start with being able to do
kind of like pick and place simple like
for one object, like let's say a plastic
banana.
Then,
we will have
kind of like
a combination that's more difficult
where the policy has to do some
reasoning to understand the task
instruction. Like put the banana into
the 2 - 1 bowl left from the left or
something along those lines.
Right? So, that you actually also need
to have some of the VLM understanding
going on there.
Yeah, then for the third criteria, we
will do a version of the famous move
Coca near Taylor Swift task from the
RT-2 paper. But, we won't tell you what
images your policy will see beforehand.
So, that will be a lot of fun deciding
the images, I think.
And
yes, and then there will be a bonus for
efficiency. So, for the smallest
model.
Yeah.
>> [snorts]
>> So, that's the first project. The
second part The second project will be
revolving around the world models.
And here,
we will be basically pushing objects.
Cuz that's like a great way to kind of
like learn dynamics of like how objects
move when you apply certain actions to
them, right? And so, yeah.
In principle,
the first task will be to push
an object kind of in a straight line.
This will be small objects cuz like the
like SO-101s don't have like a huge
range.
So, we hope we can make that work in a
meaningful manner. So, it will be a
little bit of a miniature
object.
Um,
then we will have a harder version where
there will be an obstacle in the middle.
So, you have to like kind of navigate
around the obstacle to push your object
to the goal.
Um,
and then there will be a harder task
where you have to push an unknown
object. And the bonus will be for the
policy that is most efficient in terms
of number of pushing steps
that it takes to to push to the goal.
Um, then there will be a third project
more focused on
>> [clears throat]
>> reinforcement learning.
Um, and here we are taking inspiration
from the singulation task that we also
covered
>> [clears throat]
>> in one of the papers we presented.
Um, where essentially
you start by learning
a pick and place policy
that picks up one wooden block and
places them in one of the bowls laid out
in front of the arm. And this could also
be for example
with BC. It doesn't have to be RL. Um,
but like you don't have to somehow like
bootstrap like your your policy.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> and then you start
like learning how to singulate like four
blocks that are together. Um, and then
also a more difficult task will be
singulating kind of a more
blocks than four kind of similar to how
you see um, in in the video from from
the paper.
Uh, and then the bonus will be again for
uh, the fastest single ating policy.
The fourth project will um, revolve
around keyboard typing. Um, this will be
probably inspired a little bit more
towards approaches like coders policies
where you can um, use uh,
like LLMs for prompting and you know,
maybe use some uh, predefined motion
primitives and so on.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> and um,
yeah. So, you will start by kind of
learning how to move like your your arm
to uh, four predefined points on a sheet
of paper.
Um, then you will move on to learning
how to define how to press some defined
keys on a laptop keyboard. Um, obviously
like you will have to attach something
to the gripper so you can actually press
it, but it shouldn't be too difficult.
Um,
and then
um, more difficult tasks will be typing
words on an unseen keyboard. Uh, that's
not like yours. Um, and um, but still
probably like laptop like because it's
like too big. The range is is not that
large. And then bonus also for the um,
fastest spelling of the words.
And finally, of course, we had to have
our cloth folding task too.
Um,
probably like um, you will want to get
inspired by like the diffusion policies
we've been covering um,
um, in the lecture.
Um, so here the milestones will be
starting with like grabbing an edge, uh,
making one fold, and then like
subsequent folds.
Um, and the bonus will be for um folding
the full clothes and also for the
fastest policy.
And um those are the five projects we
have. Um
I believe Alexey will send an email with
information on how to sign up for each
of the projects. Is it right?
And you will send it today.
Okay, perfect. So you will
uh you will receive information on how
to sign up for the uh projects
uh later today
uh and also uh regarding the the compute
you you should also find um
uh receive information uh shortly.
All right.
So
um
let's talk about world models.
And uh
I want to start by kind of giving like
uh an intuition um
uh
like an example of what they are. Um
maybe you have um kind of heard this
uh example before, but just to recap on
like uh what world models are or why we
are so interested in them
is um you can see this example from
baseball, right? Where in baseball you
have like a fastball um that will arrive
um to like the plate in let's say around
400 milliseconds.
And the
uh visual signal that arrives uh from
your eyes uh to your brain takes around
100 milliseconds.
And so that leaves only like 300
milliseconds to like process all the
scene,
uh decide like on your swing, and
execute it. Um and
like in principle it's like not enough
time to um decide uh how to act, right?
Um
uh but like batters like hit, you know,
around [snorts] 160 km/h balls in
baseball. Um and
like how can they do this, right? Like
how can they react so fast? And
essentially this is because like we have
this internal world model. Um where
kind of or in subconsciously we predict
where the ball is going to go. Uh and
then we initiate a swing or the
baseballer is initiate a swing based on
that prediction. Uh not based on just
the perception. If that makes sense,
right? If it if it would be only on
perception, they would not be able to
hit this fast like the this fast
fastballs.
Um and so with a good world model um
uh what you can do is essentially you
can uh act ahead of the information that
uh arrives uh from like the visual
input. Uh and that is a concept that we
are interested into bringing into
machine learning. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> because if a an agent has a good world
model, uh then it can simulate the
consequences of its actions,
uh
plan ahead, and kind of behave more
efficiently, right?
Um so
what distinguishes um a world model from
a policy, right? Um a policy or or a VLA
for example um the real we talked about
um in the last lecture, um essentially
asks a question like given my current
state uh and my goal, what is like the
action I should be taking, right? So it
it maps the the state and goal directly
to a sequence of actions. Um and the
world model asks a different question.
It asks um given my current state and an
action, what will most likely happen
next. Um so it essentially models the
transition dynamics
uh like outputting a distribution over
the um next states
uh P of ST + 1 given
ST and AT.
Um, and so this matters a lot because um
like the regular policies or VLAs in
principle
are therefore a little bit like more
blind to physical causality
um because um
it doesn't have necessarily an internal
representation of why a certain action
leads to a good outcome
um or what the physical consequences of
any uh given action would be. Right? It
doesn't necessarily have this temporal
uh model of the world.
Um
So why do we actually want world models
in robotics?
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> uh kind of I already have said it
before.
Uh if you have learned this model of
dynamics,
um then you can use it to imagine the
future.
Um so instead of immediately committing
to an action,
uh you can run let's say like a number
of rollouts
uh through your world model in your
head,
um kind of score each one, and then only
execute the best the best plan in the
real world.
Um and this is uh essentially uh very
powerful because you can explore many
hypothetical uh trajectories for the
cost of a single real one in the uh the
real world.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
Another way to think about this um is
cuz like you can be like okay, this
sounds a lot like a simulator, right?
Like uh you can take your MuJoCo or um
>> [clears throat]
>> uh whatever simulator, and uh why not
use that? And so essentially the world
model, you can think of it an analogy is
to this a learned simulator, right? It's
a data-driven um
like alternative to, uh, hand-engineered
physics engines uh, that we uh, have
been using traditionally, right? Um,
like a like a simulator with physics is
usually,
um,
built by experts. Uh, it has to obey all
the physical laws, rigid object
dynamics, uh, uh, friction, collision
geometry, and so forth. Uh, and it's
like deterministic and fast, um, but
only, um,
it's accurate to the things that have
been modeled explicitly there, right?
Uh, and anything that's has not been
modeled in the in the simulator,
I don't know, maybe it's like,
uh, deformable objects or, uh,
biological tissue,
um, then it's not going to like work,
right? It's sometimes difficult to model
everything accurately, cuz we already
seen in the lecture, there are like, uh,
some things that are just like too
difficult to model. Right? Um, and the
world model uh, flips this. So, instead
of hand-coding the physics, um,
you kind of like learn a transition
distribution from real interaction data,
right? So, any data you can find on
robot trajectories, uh, YouTube videos,
etc.
Um, like your world model will learn
whatever,
uh, dynamics are present in that data,
uh, without you having or anyone having
to explicitly, um, specify them.
And so, in principle, therefore, it
generalizes to anything that, you know,
you could capture, let's say, on on
video, for example.
Um,
um,
but I also you are bound by the data
that, uh, you have trained it on, right?
So,
uh, it might be the case that you need
like lots and lots of data,
uh, to learn, for example, physics,
right? Which for some things we already
have closed forms for.
So, that's kind of the trade-off.
Um,
I want to also give a kind of a um, a
definition about this cuz like nowadays
the term world model is kind of very
hyped and everybody calls their approach
to be a world model.
Um in principle, as I said before, um
it's
uh it models a distribution over the
next states conditioned um on the
current state, the action taken, and the
memory of the past.
Um
and um
the memory isn't uh just like necessary
for the partial observability, uh
but also it gives you the for example
the
uh the temporal sorry, the context
needed for
uh like motion, right? Like if you had
like just a single frame,
uh it can tell you like where things
are, but um the history tells you like
where where they're going, right?
Um
and um yeah, so essentially uh
I think uh important thing is that it it
in general it needs to be action
conditioned, right?
Uh like if you just have a video model
um that generates uh video from from
text,
then strictly speaking this would not be
a
a world model.
Um
and so um that's like what makes it
useful for planning and control
um that, you know, your agent needs to
be able to query
uh if it if it if I take a give a
certain action in this state, like what
state will I end up with?
>> [snorts]
>> Um
Okay, so
let's look at an early uh concrete
example of action conditioned world
model
uh working directly in pixel space. Um
this is work from Chelsea Finn et al.
from 2016.
Um and here the uh key idea is that uh
in instead of trying to predict the the
full frame
uh from scratch, which is a very hard
generative uh prop modeling problem, um
we predict the flow uh field that wraps
the
uh current image uh the current image
into the next one.
Um so, the model learns um given the
current um
image and the action I'm I'm about to
take, how will uh each pixel move?
Um and so, um
architecturally, it has like some
convolutional LSTM
um and like like the architectures that
were kind of popular at the time. Um
And um
the important thing here is to know that
um
by using this flow-based prediction
rather than uh predicting full uh
pixels, um
essentially,
it makes it like more much more
tractable to learn because it's a much
easier problem to just model motion uh
instead of like predicting like
consistently like uh visual like uh
pixel objects, right? So, it's much more
uh
structured and like less likely to to
hallucinate, for example.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
How how do you use this for robotics,
actually? So, this is um the follow-up
work called visual foresight.
And um the setup uh is visual MPC, model
predictive control, uh operating
entirely in pixel space.
Um so, here the user can specify goal
uh in different ways, like um
clicking on a certain pixel and kind of
telling them the policy, I want to move
this object from this pixel to that
pixel.
Uh
or using a image classifier.
Um and essentially, the planner then
uses the cross-entropy method that we
already saw some lectures ago
uh to iteratively then sample and refine
uh the action sequences.
>> [snorts]
>> Um and here um
one notable thing is that all the
training data is uh was collected
autonomously. So, this is just like kind
of um more or less random robot
interaction.
Um um and then um because also
the model uh learns flow,
um they also show that it generalizes
better to unseen objects and so on
because
it's easier to generalize motion instead
of like uh generalizing like
object-specific
uh tasks.
Um
this slide um summarizes this kind of
full pixel action condition world model
framework and its tradeoffs.
Um
as I fore-mentioned, the benefits are
that it's uh fully self-supervised.
Uh it doesn't require human labeling. Um
and the motion objective uh helps with
the generalization to unseen objects
because it's object-agnostic by
approach.
Um but there are some uh limitations to
working directly in pixel space. Um so,
for example here, they were using the L2
loss um which leads to blurry
predictions video predictions uh because
the model will uh average uh
over uncertainty rather than uh
committing to a sharp uh outcome as we
also covered in previous lectures.
Um
and then if you roll this over uh like
extended temporal horizon, like this
will um drift away and the errors
accumulate. Uh and then of course um so,
the model learns uh
um
flow, but then the visual MPC like
operates in pixel space, right? And so,
um
um evaluating the full image sequences
uh
for every candidate actions uh at test
time is is computationally quite
expensive.
So,
because of that, right? Um there is this
kind of like other paradigm that asks,
what if instead of doing this planning
with um, like uh, cross entropy method
in pixel space,
uh, what if we compress those
observations into a compact latent
latent representation,
um, and then did all the dynamics and
planning in the latent space?
Right? The And the intuition is that
most of the information, um,
uh, in a raw image is like not
necessarily relevant for control, right?
Like there's like a lot of like, let's
say, I don't know, background pixels
that maybe like it's not really
necessary to model or be able to
reconstruct to, uh, take optimal, um,
decisions to for manipulation, for
example.
Um,
so here is the general structure of how
latent action condition world models
work.
Um, so the obser- it's pretty simple.
The observations get encoded into, uh,
compact latent code.
Um, the dynamic model operates in that,
uh, entirely in that latent space. Uh,
and then it maintains a recurrent, um,
hidden state, uh, HT for the memory, um,
predicts the next latent state, uh, and
also predicts an imagined reward.
And then the policy takes,
um, the, uh,
like the memory and the, uh, latent as
an input and then outputs the actions.
Um, and crucially it does it all in in
in this latent space without, um, doing
like, uh, interactions in the real
environment.
Um, and so,
yeah, once you have a good world model,
you can then train the policy purely in
imagination,
uh, which is, of course, cheaper than
collecting lots of, uh, real-world, uh,
interaction.
So this is the original or OG uh, latent
action condition world model paper.
Though, if you want to debate who
exactly invented what,
you can ask Schmidhuber directly.
The architecture has three components,
a memory RNN M
that takes the latent and integrates it
integrates it over time.
And then
it has a small controller. Oh, sorry, it
has a vision model that encodes the
observations with a VAE.
And then it has the controller C
that takes both the latent and the H
memory as an input. And outputs the
actions.
And so it's like three kind of the the
the vision, the memory, and the
controller kind of a separate modules.
So, one handles the perception, the
other the the temporal prediction, and
the last one the control.
>> [snorts]
[clears throat]
>> Yeah, as I said, the the vision model is
just a VAE. It's the variation
autoencoder
that we already saw in the lecture.
The reconstruction on the right looks
reasonable.
It's not perfect,
but it kind of captures the structure of
the scene. And in general, like for
these approaches, we don't necessarily
need like for these latent approaches,
we don't necessarily need
pixel-perfect reconstructions.
We just need that the kind of latent
variable Z contains enough information
for the controller to act on.
That's kind of the important bit.
And for the memory model,
they use an RNN
with mixture density network.
And this is uh
kind of important because um,
this way with the the kind of the
mixture
of Gaussians they can handle like
multi-modality
um,
in [snorts]
uh, in many environments cuz you might
have like many uh,
plausible next states depending on the
stochastic elements in your in your
environment.
Um, and as we al- also saw before a
single Gaussian would like um,
average them out.
Um,
and so essentially the the job of the
memory model is um,
uh, two things to track what um,
uh,
has been happening in the past via the
the hidden states
and uh, predicting what will come next
uh,
as a proper distribution over the latent
states.
Um,
uh, in this paper the controller is is
very simple. It's actually just like a
single fully connected layer uh, mapping
uh, the latent uh, and HT and the uh,
the latent and the memory um, states to
to an action.
Um, and so here kind of the
intuition behind this is that uh, the
world model should be doing all the
heavy lifting in terms of representation
so that the controller doesn't need to
be expressive.
Um,
and um,
in some later more modern uh, works that
we will discuss later
uh, you will kind of see like a
reflection of of this idea.
Um,
uh, interestingly here um, this
controller doesn't get trained with back
propagation but uh, black box
evolutionary uh,
uh, optimization algorithm uh, which is
essentially very very similar to the
cross entropy method um,
um, that we've seen before.
Um, and here
uh,
the reason for using a gradient free
method is basically that
um, because the world model rollouts
involves uh stochastic um
sampling steps that makes end-to-end
differentiation a bit more difficult.
Um,
they just like treat the world model as
a black box and uh optimize the
controller parameters directly against
it.
Here are um
some results. Uh
on the left you can see how the
uh latent dream actually looks like uh
during training. And so you can see it's
like blurry and uh um kind of a bit
abstract. Um, not like a clear
reconstruction um of the environment,
but good enough for the controller to
learn from.
Right? So the the car is like uh
navigating
mostly inside the tracks
um in this imagined world.
Um
and on the right uh you can see a nice
ablation of what happens if you remove
for example the memory component of this
approach.
Uh
so [clears throat] you can see that the
car drives almost immediately out of
tracks um because it can see where it is
right now, but uh without the memory
doesn't have like a sense for its
velocity or or or the curvature and you
know, it's not able to maybe like
anticipate some some turns.
Uh here are the two main environments
they evaluated on. So the the car racing
task and the VizDoom, like the
first-person shooting game.
Um and um
yeah, what's notable is for
um
it's actually for the
for the uh shooter game um that it's
actually quite complex, like both
uh visually um like there are like many
enemies moving around in the game. Um
and it's like a much harder perception
task than the car racing uh environment.
Um and like the fact that the VAE can
compress
um data into the latent code that's
useful for control
um, and the RNN can then, um,
um, predict forward in that space,
uh, well enough for the controller to
train
is actually quite strong for like, uh,
2018.
Um, so it's it's pretty impressive,
actually.
Okay. Um,
so here is now a fundamental problem
with this approach or with this world
models approach, um, that's that's worth
kind of understanding, um, a bit more
carefully.
And that is, um,
that without, uh, priors, um, it will
start drifting very very easily. Um, so
during training the VAE encodes real
observations into the, um, ZT latent.
Um,
and the RNN is trained on those real,
uh, latent codes, right? Um, but then
during imagination phase, right, there
are no, uh, real observations, and the
RNN has to feed its own hallucinated,
uh, latents back into itself as the next
step. Um, so there is like this kind of
fundamental like
distribution, uh, mismatch,
uh, here. And, um,
and that's because the VAE was, let's
say, like trained independently of of
the RNN, for example.
Right? It encodes [clears throat] the
observations, but not the model's
beliefs.
Um, and so in order to fix this, like,
you would need to learn a a prior, um,
of, um, the latent, um, ZT given, um,
the the the memory, uh,
uh, state HT.
So, like a distribution over the
current, uh, latent that's conditioned
on the deterministic hidden state,
uh, HT.
Um,
and so that's kind of the issue here,
um, that, um,
like the RNN receives hallucinated, uh,
uh, inputs at test time.
Um,
the fix to this, um, is, uh, was
proposed by the recurrent state space,
uh, model, um, or RSSM,
uh, that kind of directly addresses, um,
this issue.
Um, and here the design choice is, um,
splitting the latent state into two
parts, um, so there is a deterministic,
uh, HT flow, uh, that goes through the
RNN and is never sampled. Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> so it kind of carries the memory, uh,
across time.
Um, and then the second part is to have
a stochastic, uh,
um,
latent, um, ZT that, um, captures the
uncertainty around the state, around the
current state.
And so, um,
then during training, um, you uh, kind
of infer, um,
the latent ZT from the actual
observation, um, so that's your
posterior. And then during imagination,
um, you can sample ZT from a learned
prior. That's like the model that we
just said that was missing from the
Schmidhuber paper.
Um,
>> [clears throat]
>> that only needs, um, the hidden state
HT.
Uh, so it doesn't require the actual
observation, right? And in order to, to
train this prior, um, they proposed
using the, uh, KL loss, um, that forces
the, this to stay close to the posterior
during training, so that the imagined
latents, um, then stay in the region,
um, that the model actually understands,
right? So it's close in latent space.
>> [snorts]
>> Um,
yeah.
Uh, here is how, um,
this works, uh, during imagination. So
during this closed-loop uh, inference,
um at each step, the policy reads the
current uh
uh hidden state and and latent and
outputs an action um
and then the world model advances. So,
the RNN updates the hidden state and the
next uh latent is sampled uh from the
prior conditioned on the new uh hidden
state.
Uh and so, no real observation is needed
anywhere um in this loop.
And then, the imagined reward is
accumulated um over the rollout under
policy um can optimize uh against this.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
Yeah, and here
like you can see again like this
deterministic path, right? Um
>> [clears throat]
>> so, while the stochastic part of the ZT
um is um sampled fresh uh at each step
from the prior, um
the kind of the RNN HT like remains
deterministic, right? It doesn't get uh
corrupted. Um so,
yeah, this is what makes it kind of work
in in in practice.
Uh to make it like the world model
stable enough that uh you can uh roll
out uh
kind of very long um
behaviors
and get a meaningful training signal.
Um the this slide here is the step from
um the
Planet uh paper or where the RSSM was
introduced to Dreamer uh V1.
And uh motivation is quite simple.
Um so, the paper we just uh covered uh
still actually uses the cross-entropy
method uh from scratch at every single
time step.
Um so, it samples like thousands of
action sequences, rolls them out, and
refeeds the the Gaussian and so forth.
Um and that's
quite expensive, right? To do this all
at uh
at test time.
And so the the question um Dreamer uh V1
asks is, why not um instead of doing
that um
kind of amortize the planning into a
learned policy?
Um so here they uh run the the
imagination rollouts during training,
and then they back propagate through the
differentiable um recurrent state space
model dynamics.
And train a actor-critic um to
basically
internalize what the cross-entropy
method was doing at test time in the
previous version.
Um so this way at
uh deployment time, you can now just run
the policy, and you don't you don't have
a planning loop that's needed anymore.
Um and so
yeah, and you still have the two
training procedures where you first
train the world model
um on the let's say real data, um
then you freeze the world model, um roll
out imagined trajectories in latent
space, and uh then train the
actor-critic by back propagating through
those uh frozen dynamics.
Okay. Uh
Daydreamer is a direct application of
the Dreamer
uh algorithm or paradigm um to real
physical uh robots.
Um so it's the same uh kind of
algorithm, same hyperparameters,
uh just running on actual uh robots.
Um
And the uh key number here is on the
quadruped, right? So 1 hour of real
interaction is enough to learn uh
walking on the quadruped uh from
scratch.
Um and so the world model basically um
lets you train for the equivalent of
days in imagination
um from that one hour of real-world
interaction data.
Um and that's kind of a very um
um
very one of the appealing uh
properties of this paradigm.
Um
the paper also has a couple of nice
contributions
um to make Dreamer work on real robots
uh or hardwares like asynchronous
asynchronous training and inference
like where the policy runs at a uh
control frequency in real time
uh while the world model trains in the
background.
Um I recommend checking the paper for
for more details.
Um
And so I think the best way to
understand what we've been building so
far is maybe like the scene from uh
Matrix
uh the movie if you have watched this
before.
Uh this there is a scene where like uh
Neo uh dreams about like different
martial arts
uh like you know practicing like kung fu
and accumulates like years of experience
worth while dreaming and then learns how
to master
uh kung fu essentially completely in
imagination, right? And that's kind of
the dream of world models. Um so don't
spend hours like watching your robot
like fail um in real world
just build a a model um
that's uh good enough train in
imagination uh and then transfer.
Um
Um to summarize, I mean if you're
interested in this, there's a whole
series of
uh Dreamer papers
um
kind of
I summarize kind of the main key points
um of each of them.
Um so we started like with the
Schmidhuber paper
um
uh that was kind of the uh proof of
concept um the first one I think uh
agent that was purely trained in
imagination.
Then
uh we innovation was the RSSM planet in
2019.
>> [clears throat]
>> Then Dreamer V1 that replaced the
cross-entropy method
with the actor-critic
policy.
Then
in Dreamer 2 and 3, there were like some
more improvements to the training per se
like categorical latents, KL balancing,
and so forth.
I think the Dreamer V3
was very impressive cuz it was the first
one
to obtain diamonds in the Minecraft from
pixels. And this is like a very very
long like over two two over 20,000
actions I think
that the agent needs to take to do this.
And then last year Dreamer V4 managed to
kind of repeat this.
But
without any online interaction at all,
purely offline.
Dreamer V4 actually introduces two
important changes worth understanding
and that serve kind of as a nice
transition to to the next algorithmic
framework.
The [clears throat] first one is that
here in Dreamer V4
the dynamics model is pre-trained on
unlabeled video
without any actions required.
And this is done by a flow matching
learning a history of the latents.
And then
you can fine-tune this on
with actions to get a action condition
model.
And so this decoupling is quite nice
because it means that you can leverage
more like videos and scalable
uh data sources that don't you don't
have necessary actions for.
Uh and then the second one I think
they replace the hidden state of the
recurrent neural network um with a
transformer's KV cache. Um this
gives your model much more expressive
and longer range memory than a fixed
size RNN hidden state.
Um
And as I said like the
they had very nice
uh like results with
the Minecraft diamonds offline.
And um
yeah and yeah Danny Jar they also uh
uh showed that
it works also in one of my papers
the the sort paper the the data we
collected here that was collected
autonomously uh for a different project.
So you can see that it can also model uh
real
robot videos.
That's very nice.
But there is a fundamental limitation um
>> [clears throat]
>> with
everything we've covered so far.
Um and that is that
the latent spaces trained for this world
models like dreamer
are typically specific to a certain
domain. Right? So it's either Minecraft
or
DM control or some particular robot
you're training for.
And so the latents are um
like compact and useful but they are
kind of like specific to whatever
environment that you are
like targeting.
Uh and it's like difficult to
transfer them.
Um
And so if we want a world model that
understands the general visual world um
you know like that we can learn like we
can throw it anything right?
No matter if it's like internet videos,
robot data, Minecraft, whatever.
Um then like a small like
domain-specific
like model is not going to cut it.
And this brings us to the next part of
the lecture,
which is about generative video models.
Right? So here, instead of
a compact latent world model trained on
one single domain,
um the question we are trying to answer
is what if we scale this up to
internet-scale video and learn a more
general model of how the visual world
actually works.
Um and if you want to apply
transformer-based generative models to
video,
uh before diving into any approaches,
like we can also think about how we can
tokenize this, right?
Um we already covered like how to
tokenize images before.
Um you might just think like, "Okay,
I can just take my VIT,
run this through each frame, and you
know,
that's my video tokenized."
Um but this runs immediately into a
problem, um right?
Uh and that is that it really explodes
your context length.
Um so
a 256 by 256 image
with like the 16 by 16 patches we saw
before
will give you around 256 tokens per
frame. Um you know, that sounds like
fine. Um
but [clears throat] if you multiply this
by, let's say, 200 frames
for a 10-second clip at 20 FPS, now you
have like over 50,000 tokens.
Uh and that's kind of at the limit of
the context length for GPT-4, for
example.
Uh and that's only for a 10-second like
video clip, right? So the challenge is
like how can we tokenize video in a way
um that's temporally aware and compact
enough um that we can fit it into a
reasonable context window.
And we kind of need to solve this before
we can
>> [clears throat]
>> um build generative video models
um that operate at any uh useful scale.
>> [clears throat]
>> So,
we could probably do a full lecture on
video tokenization.
But here is um kind of the main gist of
Sorry.
>> [clears throat]
>> The main gist um of things to be aware
of.
Um
the core problem, as you can guess, is
that video is essentially very
fundamentally extremely redundant.
All right?
>> [clears throat]
>> So, um consecutive frames are uh highly
correlated. Uh and as we said, like a
naive tokenizer will ignore this
completely.
So, there are like three main axes um
uh along which you can compress video
tokens.
Uh and they are typically um independent
and composable.
Um the first one is um spatial
compression, right? That's kind of like
very obvious.
So, you can use like deeper encoders,
uh use larger strides, um and kind of um
use like a lot
Sorry. Uh use a lot of the
VQ-style
encoders that we also covered uh in the
past lectures
uh to kind of get a more spatial
compression.
The second axis is temporal compression.
Um this means like merging multiple
frames into
uh like a single token.
Um you can do this
uh non-causally, for example, with uh
tuplets, uh treating a chunk of images
as uh 3D uh as a single 3D patch, or um
you can do this
cause causally by aggregating past
frames
um
into [clears throat] a single token
while decoding
frame by frame.
Um the causal version is for example the
one that you really want
if you want your model to work in
streaming
or control settings. And for example
Dreamer V4 or for example the Cosmos
models uh use some sort of causal video
tokenizers.
Um and the last one is doing adaptive
compression.
Um so you can think of this as
um
um compress compressing the videos
depending on the complexity of the
images.
Um so this means that
if you have like simple static frames
where there is not a lot a lot a lot of
things going on um that you will use
less tokens to represent um
those frames or those video snippets.
While if um the video is very complex um
or I don't know maybe you are doing like
your robot task with a pick and place or
something um if it's like a dynamic
scene that you assign or allocate more
tokens to represent that cuz you might
want finer details uh and so on.
And um
And yeah and you can combine um ideas
from these different
kind of like compression
axis.
So for example
Cosmos has different tokenizers but for
example one of them
applies like eight fold
>> [clears throat]
>> uh spatial compression that's like eight
fold and also the same for temporal. Um,
so this means that for instead of the
over five 50,000 tokens um
uh from like applying the naive frame by
frame VIT,
um like this will
compress the same 10-second clip into
around
uh 100 tokens.
All right.
Um,
so
when we scale to internet video, um
we kind of hit like uh another question,
which is um where do actions live?
Um, in the action condition world models
we've covered so far, the actions are um
explicitly inputs to the model.
Um, so you feed your observations and um
the future actions in and you could get
future uh
states out. And this requires action
label data, which is usually scarce at
internet scale.
Um
So
there are two kind of uh alternative
paradigms.
Um, so the first uh to this um which uh
we can say that they're like video-based
action prediction models.
Um, the first one is
uh like a world action model or WAM.
Um, so it's a single model um that
jointly predicts video and actions
uh end-to-end. Um
And so um
unlike uh the Dreamer-based
uh models where actions are inputs that
condition the world model,
um
here in in WAMs the actions are outputs.
So um the model generates a future video
uh and uh predicts the actions uh that
produce it um at the same time together.
Um
So
one also difference to to uh with
respect to the Dreamer series is that
here this typically gets initialized
from a general
pre-trained video backbone.
So the world model
knowledge comes also from this
pre-trained backbone
rather from just like pure robot
interaction data.
And Dream Zero is one example of this.
The second [clears throat]
the second kind of family
is
our video action models or VAMs.
Where essentially you freeze a video
backbone that's been pre-trained on
internet video,
extract the video features and now train
a lightweight inverse dynamics model or
IDM
on top of it using only robot data for
the IDM part.
And so this is for example mimic video
approach.
And here again the video backbone is
doing the heavy lifting of the dynamics
and the action head just needs to learn
the mapping from the visual features to
the robot actions.
Which requires much less data.
And so yeah, so where the actions live
essentially gives a little bit of
trade-off
between the data requirements,
scalability and how tightly the world
model is
>> [clears throat]
>> coupled to control
which we will
talk a little bit about.
Um.
At this point in the lecture you might
be wondering like okay.
Didn't we just say before that video is
expensive?
Why use video backbones at all?
Because we said like it's very token
hungry and it's computationally
expensive, right?
And.
I think I kind of already hinted at
this, but
you can see
uh
again like what this buys you by looking
at
what has been until now kind of the
state of the art, right? Of the VLAs
that we've been covering
um
cuz like if you think about it like on
how like the kind of the VLA paradigm
works, right? Um you typically train you
take a pre-trained VLM, right? Um that's
been pre-trained on some like I don't
know like captioning visual question
answering tasks. Um
>> [clears throat]
>> and then you fine-tune this into a large
with a large-scale robot
teleoperation data. And so the VLM will
bring like some semantic pre-trained
knowledge like it knows what cutting a
carrot means. Um but it's been trained
on this static image text pairs.
Uh and so hence like it doesn't have
this um
understanding of temporal dynamics, no
sense of
how actions change the state. Um or
physical causality as we said before.
And
therefore like
to um
uh we need to collect lots of robot
teleop data
to then like adapt this model to
understand all of this, right? Um
all this like dynamics, like contact
physics, what happens when you grasp
something.
Uh none of that comes from the VLM
pre-training.
Uh and so you're paying a very high data
cost
to compensate for a representation
that was never designed for control.
And so instead if instead of that um we
build on top of a pre-trained video
backbone, we can now flip the recipe
um where now instead of starting from a
VLM, um, that's been trained on this
static image text pairs and hoping that
the robot data teaches its its dynamics,
um, we can now start from this video
model, um, that's been pre-trained on
large-scale internet scale, uh, video
data.
Right? So, beyond, um,
semantics now,
uh, it knows what cutting card means,
um, it also has now visual dynamics
baked in uh, right from the get-go, from
the pre-trained model. And so, it
understands how, um, things, uh, move
and how actions, uh, cause changes in
the visual world. And so, this means
that now the the robotics fine-tuning
task suddenly becomes much simpler
because now you only need to learn
control. Um, so the mapping from the
visual features to the robot actions,
you don't need to teach the model
physics from scratch.
Um, and so, you will need, uh, way less
data, um, um, to get a good, uh, VLA,
uh, cuz the post-training is much more
efficient.
And, um, this is exactly what, for
example, we found out in this Mimic
Video paper,
um, that I co-authored also with, uh,
our TAs Yonas and Liam,
um, who were also interning with me at
Microsoft. And, um,
we, uh, coined this, uh, as video action
models and found that it led to a 10%
uh, boost in sample efficiency, uh,
compared to uh, pi is 0.5, uh, style VLA
models.
Um,
this slide gets, uh, a a something, uh,
fundamental about why the video backbone
approach really works.
Um,
the intuition is that, as I said before,
like this video models really learn like
in both like image semantics, uh,
physical dynamics, and um
visual action plans all at the same
time, right? And so, um
if that is true, then as I said before,
the decoders uh job should become much
more simple, like almost trivial, right?
Like you will just be translating a
visual plan into um that's already
implicit uh in the video representations
into a low-dimensional robot trajectory.
Um
And so, uh
we did this Oracle experiment where we
trained action decoders on top of um
different video representations.
Um uh and where we um saw, for example,
that if we gave it uh ground truth uh uh
latents extracted uh from future
uh frames of like things that actually
happened, um then um
the success rate was near perfect uh
regardless of whether the backbone was
fine-tuned on uh robot data or not.
Um so, this means that the pre-trained
video model uh backbone alone already
provides representations that are rich
enough to uh decode perfectly actions
with uh minimal robot data.
And um
the the gap between the uh Oracle
performance um
and um
the predicted um the Sorry, the actions
predicted um from uh
the non-Oracle uh frames
um shows you exactly where the
bottleneck is, right? So, it's the video
prediction quality, um meaning not the
action decoding part. Um so, this means
that um
the path to better robot performance in
this uh family or in this paradigm um
is very straightforward, like it's just
to build better video models. So, as the
video models become better
and approximate the oracle,
um also the downstream performance will
improve.
Okay, I don't have that much time, so I
will go
uh fast
a bit faster.
Um
>> [clears throat]
>> So, in in this architecture, uh we use
the Cosmos Predict 2 as the video
backbone, um which is this pre-trained
uh
uh generative model.
And um
rather than maybe one thing that's
interesting that is that rather than
uh generating uh uh full video at
inference time, we use a partial
denoising strategy, um where we run the
video backbone
um forward only to an intermediate flow
time,
um
and then extract the latent uh visual
plan from that point
uh to condition the action decoder.
Uh and also um
a key decision um
uh choice was here um that the video and
action components, cuz they're both
trained with flow matching, they uh have
independent flow schedules.
Um
And um yeah, there's some results.
We already covered this.
Um as I said, we
don't have to predict um we don't have
to reconstruct the video at test time,
um but just for visualization,
uh that's uh
how it looks on the right.
Um
and then
uh Dream Zero takes the
uh world action model approach we
described earlier, this joint video and
action prediction,
uh into a single model uh without a
separate uh IDM
uh decoder. Um so here this is a
and we have today also as a guest
speaker Scott Reed who is a co-author of
this paper.
Maybe you'll talk a bit about this, too.
Um
So here the architecture is a single
causal DAT that takes the video latents,
uh noisy action tokens, uh
proprioception and language as input and
then jointly denoises both the video and
actions uh using a flow matching uh with
again teacher forcing during training.
Um so here there is no real separation
between the world model and the policy
cuz it's like one model predicting both
at the same time.
Um and then inference the model runs
autoregressively. It generates chunks of
future frames uh and the corresponding
actions together um
>> [clears throat]
>> autoregressively.
Uh and it uses
uh again KV cache to make this a bit
more efficient. Um
uh that's actually one of the nice
things of this kind of approach that uh
unlike in pure video generation settings
uh because this is now a closed-loop
setting, this allows
kind of
setting ground truth observation uh to
replace the generated frames in your KV
cache after each action execution um
which allows you to bypass the
compounding errors
that are usually inherent to to pure
autoregressive video generation models.
Uh and they also have like tons of cool
engineering contributions to make this
also work at real time with a 14B
parameter model.
Um so yeah, that's also recommendable to
to check out.
Um and they also have quite nice results
um showing strong generalization
uh
with humanoids uh and also nice uh
few-shot adaptation capabilities.
Uh not all tasks are perfect as you can
see uh also cloth folding
uh or um
picking up a marker and drawing uh a
circle on the book
is still not perfect. But in general,
lots of uh very tasks um
uh like for example also the uh shoelace
knitting uh it's it's pretty impressive.
Um
So
here is a a kind of like a small
comparison slide um between uh world
action models and video action models
um and how they compare across different
data um across different axes.
Um
action condition world uh
models
win on data in the sense that uh you can
train it with any sorts of data like
successes
uh failures, play data.
Um so significantly broader amount of
data
uh compared uh to to WAMs.
Um while they uh they need like kind of
more task
um task labels [clears throat] for
instructing um instruction conditioning.
Uh so which means that if you use play
data, you would need to have uh some
hindsight relabeling at scale.
Um then um
WAMs uh have a bit of an advantage on
uh cross-embodiment um because the video
backbones uh are robot agnostic.
Um and only the action decoder needs uh
robot specific data.
Um and uh for for action condition world
models, um, cross embodiment learning
is kind of an open problem still.
Uh,
then RAMs have um better feature are
better at um retaining pre-trained
capabilities.
Um,
and um action condition models need to
learn essentially action conditioning
from scratch, which can destroy
partially um the pre-trained knowledge
of the of the model.
And then, um
sorry.
And then the action conditioned uh world
models kind of have the advantage that
they can
um
at least today
uh go beyond pure imitation by
uh also doing RL in imagination, uh
which we still haven't uh
uh seen for the other paradigm.
Um,
yeah, to close, um
everything we have seen so far, um so
Dreamer, Dream Zero, Mimic Video, etc.,
um all the approaches that we've covered
uh so far
um
typically have a decoder somewhere.
Uh, so at some point in these
approaches, and it it varies sometimes
like where,
um there is a decoder that maps back um
um
to the pixels um to reconstruct.
Um, and there is a a kind of a
a fourth uh family of algorithms that
kind of asks the asks the question,
um do we even need to predict uh the
pixels at all?
And
that's kind of the question that um the
Jepa framework tries to uh address,
um
where the idea is that um
instead of predicting what the next
frame looks like, um
you just predict what the next frame's
embedding will look like.
Uh, so you encode the current frame, um,
predict the next latent given, uh, your
action, then encode, um, the actual next
frame, uh, with the same encoder, uh,
and minimize the distance between the
two, uh, latents.
Um, so you don't have any
reconstruction, no decoder, uh, no no
pixel loss.
Um, and the appeal is like obvious cuz
now you, you know, predicting in this
latent space is also cheaper,
um, and you're not, you know, wasting
any capacity and and trying to model all
the pixels.
Um,
uh, but of course there is a catch in
the sense that, um,
if the encoder maps, uh, every frame to
the same vector, then the prediction
loss is trivially zero, um, and that is
this kind of representation collapse,
um, and this kind of central problem
that this Jepa family, um,
um, has been trying to solve over the
last years. This is kind of the this
fundamental challenge to any,
um, self-supervised, uh, method that
doesn't reconstruct the the input.
Um, and so there are then, uh, a few
different, um, approaches that, uh,
address this. Um,
uh,
like V Jepa 2 uses, um, an EMA target
encoder, uh, so a a slow-moving copy of
the encoder, um, that the predictor
must, uh, kind of, uh, chase. Uh, or the
Dino world model uses, uh,
um,
pre-trained encoder, um, but doesn't do
then end-to-end learning, um, and then
the most recent work, uh,
the world model,
uh, uses a Gaussian regularizer, um,
that forces the latent distribution, uh,
to spread out making, um,
this kind of constant vector, uh,
solutions, uh, not possible.
Um, um
yeah, so to put everything together uh
for today's lecture,
uh we started with with this formula.
Uh predicting the next state um given
the the current state, actions, and the
memory.
Um and then um all the approaches we've
covered today
uh have like kind of provided kind of a
different answer to the same question.
And they differ in terms of like how you
represent a state,
uh where the actions live, and what kind
of uh data we can use.
Um and I guess I'm way over over time.
Um so yeah, I'll leave you with that.
Thank you.